i had a lot of requests for this video
today we're going to show you how to
very a to b
get rid of puffy eyes as well as the
dark circles around the eyes and it just
so happens that the underlying cause or
at least the most common cause of both
of these conditions
is the same thing which is very very
good but typically when you research on
this you're going to find
well it's just fatigue it's lack of
sleep you're stressed it's a hypothyroid
condition
it's called hashimoto's where you're
having this
lymphatic tissue that's backing up into
the system
or it might be an early sign of
epstein-barr virus or maybe it's alcohol
or maybe it's allergy right well i'm
just going to tell you these are not
very common causes of
dark circles underneath the eyes or
puffy eyes now it is true if you have
damaged kidneys you are going to
definitely have
puffiness around the eyes okay it's not
as common as the thing i'm going to talk
about but it can happen and the reason
why it happens is you're getting this uh
this fluid backing up into the tissues
it's called interstitial
fluid retention
because there's a loss of protein in the
urine and a loss of protein in your
blood so anytime you don't have enough
albumin which is a protein in your blood
you start retaining fluid and you can
get edema and puffiness around the eyes
transverse bands on your nails so if you
see a couple uh i don't know horizontal
bands around your fingers
you might want to get your kidneys
checked and there could be parasites
okay that's another cause as well but
let's talk about the most common cause
of both puffiness and dark circles
underneath your eyes
and the answer is
hyperinsulinemia
what is that that is too much insulin
in your blood you have insulin
resistance which is causing your
pancreas to produce too much insulin to
compensate so that's really what's
happening you see this a lot in early
diabetics type 2 and you see it nearly
always in pre-diabetics and of course
the majority of the rest of the
population has insulin resistance so you
probably see this very common in people
you can look at their eyes and if they
have this puffiness around the eyes and
this darkened pigment
suspect
they've been eating a lot of carbs
because it's the carbs that is the big
trigger to this high level of insulin
now another condition that you see with
insulin resistance as well as
hyperinsulinemia
is acanthosis cancer what does
that mean that's a condition where you
have
darkened
folds on your body like underneath your
armpits like a darkened band
on your neck you might see it under the
armpits or next to the breast tissue but
that condition which is a
hyper pigmentation problem is also
caused by high levels of insulin so the
more insulin you have the more melanin
that's pumped out and that can show up
in a darker
layer of skin now of course if you're
consuming all these carbs right and you
have high levels of insulin and insulin
resistance you're going to be
one big fluid retaining sponge okay
you're going to be holding fluid all
over the place and
one common area that you see it is in
the ankles and then the other one is in
the eyes right underneath the eyes or on
the top of the eyelid too so i mean i
could look at someone and go wow that
guy's eating carbs you could just see
their eyes are all puffy and usually
they don't have a clue that that is the
reason why they think it's maybe genetic
or it's a lack of sleep but it's
actually the carbs and also carbs cause
the retention of sodium so they're
holding
sodium
yet they're very very deficient in
potassium so
what can be done about this there's four
things that you can do right now to
reverse this okay number one stop eating
carbs you can't get rid of this without
stopping carbs okay that's number one
number two
stop
snacking okay
snacking is a killer every time you eat
guess what you trigger insulin so you
have to stop snacking
and number three you have to start with
something called intermittent fasting so
intermittent fasting is a pattern of
eating and not eating you want to
combine that with your low carb diet we
call it a ketogenic plan the combination
of low carb and intermittent fasting
without snacking of course is
powerful to handle the bags as well as
the dark circles now there's one more
thing you can do to speed things up and
that is to start taking
potassium or consume foods high in
potassium not bananas okay or potatoes
you want to do things like beet greens
in your salad uh more salad itself like
seven to ten cups you want to do
avocados and avocados like 800
milligrams of potassium you can do
broccoli
mushrooms they're all very high in
potassium so that's the four things
number one stop your carbs stop your
snacking start doing intermittent
fasting
and start to beef up no pun intended
your potassium and watch those bags go
away and also watch the darkened circles
underneath the eyes go away that's
usually going to take a little bit
longer could take between two three
maybe in four weeks before you start
noticing a difference now if you haven't
seen my new tutorial on how to do keto i
put it right here check it out
you